hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts sharing data about
genomic variants a clinical and
scientific imperative presented by
Robert Koch Teigen he is a professor for
the future of innovation in society and
Consortium for science policy and
outcomes at Arizona State University
I am Marjorie Torres elaborate and I'll
be your moderator for today's bet we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by libraries
Lavin's is relating scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many of your
questions since we have time for at the
end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hear in the
presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom or center of your screen or use
the ask a question box to let us know
that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Robert cook geniune I will now turn the
presentation over to him so I guess
we're ready to get started and let me
start this presentation by just setting
the context and give you an idea of
where we're gonna go I'm gonna start by
explaining some cases just exemplifying
some cases of why the interpretation of
genomic variants is important why it
matters in clinical care and why the
need for data sharing has become so much
more apparent in recent years and will
progress for some from those specific
cases to some of the background on
policy
and issues that have come up with the in
dealing with this cluster of issues over
the past several years and then we'll
progress through a specific case where
we're trying to deal with the issue of
data sharing about genomic variants
specifically focusing on the brca1 and
brca2 genes that have been tested for
over two decades on millions of people
worldwide and I'll finish with some
ideas about what we can do to improve
the situation so the reason that genomic
variants and data sharing are seen as
being kind of they grow up together
comes from the convergence of two
technologies one is the ability to
characterize DNA particularly DNA
sequencing but also hybridization
methods and and polymerase chain
reaction and all sorts of other ways of
analyzing DNA have converged with
another miraculous technology that is
computing technologies and in recent
years cloud technologies to create a lot
of data and the ability to sequence a
genome which seemed to be a fantasy when
the idea of the human genome project was
proposed in 1985 has become something
that we can do in a matter of hours and
for less than a thousand dollars in 2018
so we're generating reams of data and
those data are being shared on lots of
people about lots of diseases and we're
following people over time and trying to
link the data to what happens to those
people do they get sick what have they
been exposed to what images do we have
of their brains and their bodies can we
see tumors in their bodies do we can we
correlate what's going on in the genome
with what's going on in that person's
body so lots of data lots of genes lots
of people and lots of linkages among
data bases so what does this matter for
clinical care and the way I wanted to
illustrate that is to use two cases one
is related to the brca1 and brca2 genes
just think of a woman who lives in the
United States is being tested in the
United States by a lab here but her one
parent is from Mexico and the other
parent is from Nigeria and she's tested
and found to have a variant in the BRCA
gene that is something that is not the
common sequence in a particular position
that's related to exon 11 of the brca1
gene and she has two people in her
family who have developed cancer younger
than average and therefore you as a
clinician might be thinking oh gosh
maybe this is somebody who's at special
risk and now we've got a variant that we
don't actually don't know how to
interpret now why don't we know how to
interpret it well because most of the
testing for brca1 and 2 has been done in
European and North American populations
by labs that are connected to robust and
well-funded health systems but a lot of
the populations around the globe have
not been tested and for these particular
two genes it's quite common for
different mutations to be more common in
different populations so the three
mutations that most people are familiar
with in Ashkenazi Jewish populations
that account for well over 90 percent of
the risk in those populations it's not
the same mutation that you would find
most commonly in China or Nigeria or
Mexico or Iceland so we're even 20 years
more than two decades into common
genetic testing for brca1 and 2 we're
still coming upon new variants that we
don't know how to interpret particularly
for populations that are outside of the
the North American and European
continents so that's one example another
example is a child who died at age 2 in
status epilepticus and this is a case
where a mutation had been detected in a
sodium channel
in a gene that encodes a voltage-gated
sodium channel in interneurons and it
was declared by the lab to be a variant
of unknown significance although this
particular variant had been reported in
a child from Canada who had severe
epilepsy of infancy and the reason this
matters is that the treatment for sodium
channel caused epilepsy is pretty much
the opposite of treatment for other
kinds the most common kinds of epilepsy
and in fact the standard epileptic drugs
make this syndrome called Dravet
Syndrome
they actually make it worse and this
child had a mutation that was detected
had been reported in two publications in
the literature and was actually subject
of a patent that said yes it's one of
those mutations that causes this disease
but it it was reported at the time by
the laboratory as not pathogenic and in
fact not we don't quite know how to
interpret it I raised this because now
it's more than a decade later his case
is still not in the medical literature
where other people can use that
information to make clinical inferences
so this is these are two case examples
of why the sharing of data about genomic
variance is really important not only
for advancing science but also in very
practical decision-making in the clinic
these are not new problems there are
many statements about the need to share
data in the case of science in order to
prove that what you've said is true you
need to share your information and in
the case of clinical inference this is
the whole idea of evidence-based
medicine these three reports of the 2002
2011 and 2012 reports from the National
Academy of Sciences engineering and
medicine all state these principles and
basically they say that we need access
to the data
and we also need access to enough
information about how the data were
interpreted to be able to verify the
claims that are being made about the
data this is layered on top of a
movement that I think is where policy
will eventually rest but actually has
not been incorporated into the way we do
business these days and that is that
information about you has to be
accessible to you a right to access your
information and also a right to send the
information about you to anyone that you
want to so the idea here is your genome
belongs to you this is something that's
a norm but it's not established in
practice now this is just one example of
many many examples of the need for
collective action that is no one
institution is ever going to be able to
interpret all these variants for all the
genes in all the people for all the
conditions that we care about in the
early 1960s now Garrett Hardin wrote
this very famous essay called the
tragedy of the Commons in which he said
well you know when we're confronted with
these problems of collective action and
when we've got something that is
valuable to all of us we can confront
the tragedy which is everybody's can be
either overuse it or in the case of data
if people put their fingers on it and
use it as a proprietary asset we've got
a problem because a common resource is
going to be underused Elinor Ostrom
pictured here in this slide was an
economist who got the well actually she
was in everything she was more than an
economist she was a sociologist and a
political scientist and she got the
Nobel Prize in Economics for her work
that said you know Garret Hardin said
there only two solutions to that problem
one is the government steps in and tries
to fix things by regulating it and the
other is let the market decide and in
the case of a Commons you actually it's
by definition the sort of thing that a
market is not going to solve and what
she pointed out was actually we come
across
these problems although all the time and
it turns out that when people talk to
each other we can come up with rules and
ways of doing business that enable us to
make sense of the world and actually
those things are called Commons and we
can make them work and she came up with
a set of rules that tend to work and
they depend on people and institutions
developing the rules and being able to
enforce those rules by defining a
community and coming up with the process
of both crafting the rules and doing
something about them in the concept of
genomics one of the salient features of
the human genome project is that it was
set as a an open science initiative what
you're looking at here is the original
statement this is john sulston 'he's
handwriting john just died a couple of
weeks ago at age 75 of stomach cancer
but in 1996 he wrote this on the board
at at a hotel in Bermuda and these
became known as the Bermuda principles
for data sharing this was for the
high-throughput sequencing centers that
were participating in the human genome
project and the rule was if you're
generating sequence data you have to
post it on the internet within 24 hours
and the whole idea was let's make this
information available to everybody and
the labs that are getting all this money
to do this high-tech whiz-bang science
aren't the only people that get access
to the data so this is a precedent for
open science but it doesn't really it
doesn't really apply to data that
involves human beings and clinical
information so the Bermuda principles
while they work for pure science and for
data like DNA sequence data coming from
a few centers they've had to be modified
as we've turned to sources of data that
involve identifiable human beings in a
clinical context these Bermuda
principles have been modified for other
and they've been embedded in policies
like the National Human Genome Research
Institute at NIH in the policies that
were first stated in 2003 and then
reiterated in 2014 and on this slide we
see a bunch of other examples of
policies that have emerged over the
years but the problem is that the data
that we're dealing with these days are
much more geographically dispersed there
are different kinds of data there are
many more linkages among the different
kinds of databases and the world of
biotechnology and medicine has gotten a
whole lot more complicated since the
Bermuda principles were enunciated in
1996 so some examples of things that can
make this more difficult one is the
number of players when this agreement
was reached to Bermuda there were only
five countries involved in the human
genome project and then China joined in
1996 and you could get representatives
from all the major labs into one room of
less than 50 people as one example of
kind of the similar trying to form a
Commons effort in the current context in
genomics the Global Alliance has more
than 70 countries more than 400
organizations and more than 800 people
and that's a whole lot more complicated
thing to deal with another feature of
course is it's not just DNA sequence
we're also talking about electronic
health records genealogic data what
people have been exposed to where they
live how old they are what country they
come from where they live now and other
information we may even have data about
their pulse rate or stuff that's coming
in from them about their exercise and
activity through smartwatches and other
sources of information so it's more
complicated the data are much more
diverse and we're not going to be able
to have a single rule like the share
your data every 24 hours
the even in the case of the Bermuda
principles it turns out that it was kind
of complicated to get agreement on
sharing the information and it wasn't
clear exactly what information should be
included so let's take DNA sequences an
example even just thinking about DNA
sequence variants there are many layers
to the data one is the raw sequence
reads that come off of the machines that
are doing the sequencing the next layer
is so you take all the snippets of
information from individual reads and
you assemble those into a sequence and
then you take that assembled sequence
and you compare it to the reference
genome to identify variants and then
once you've identified the variants you
have to say do these variants mean
anything what do we know about them
which ones are associated with disease
so even at the level of DNA sequence and
figuring out what that means we've got
four layers of technical standards and
interpretations that need to be imposed
on the data to be able to make a
clinical inference and that's without
thinking about the correlations to who
gets cancer who doesn't get cancer
whether they're being followed over time
what images we have of their brains and
bodies and things like that so this
information Commons has gotten a whole
lot more complicated and it's not just
about DNA sequence it's also about
proteins cells whole organisms and the
environment in which we live so some of
the challenges that come into being when
you start dealing with data data about
people is that you have to deal with the
fact that the information is coming from
people under usually under the context
of informed consent and moreover
governments all over the world have
discovered hey you know what the data
about people especially medical
information might be really valuable and
thats related to biotechnology and
countries in the south and in the
developing world
don't completely trust
the countries in North America and
Europe and rich countries and would like
to preserve some of the value from the
information that they're creating and
they are passing laws that restrict the
free flow of samples and information
across national borders for very
understandable reasons so information
and samples actually have a layer of law
in many many countries India Russia
China all have laws saying you cannot
export data without giving getting
permission for doing so
moreover even without the national laws
these are data about human beings and in
fact some of these data are incredibly
private variants in the brca1 and 2 gene
are not the sort of thing that you want
your children to be asked about in their
junior high class because somebody's
gotten the internet and said hey Judy do
you have a variant in your BRCA gene I
see that your mom does so these are
highly private information this is very
private information and it needs to be
subjected to review and control and
people are not going to share their
information unless they feel like it's
safe and it's being used in a
responsible manner manner so these are
all issues of data flow that don't
really come up when you're talking about
raw DNA sequence from a reference
population so what are the policy issues
that come up we did an analysis of the
clinical integration of next-generation
sequencing into clinical genomics we did
this as a Delphi process where you go to
experts and you say what do you think of
the problems and what can we do about
those problems and we bundled problems
into 19 categories those were things
like reimbursement of genetic tests the
FDA regulation of genetic tests coverage
and reimbursement decisions and issues
like that intellectual
property gene patents and among those 19
categories we had one that was data
sharing and the data sharing came out as
being tied for number one with
reimbursement as being really important
and it was dead last in people's
estimation of whether we were going to
be able to do anything about it so why
is that well it's because this all our
survey was going on at the time around
when the Supreme Court of the United
States invalidated the brca1 and 2
patents and it became readily apparent
at that point that data about genomic
variants in brca1 and brca2 were not
being shared the most conspicuous case
was of course the proprietary database
that was held by myriad genetics as part
of its genetic testing service in Salt
Lake City but it's not just married
genetics it's also other laboratories
and it's in fact national health
services and in laboratories and data
bases all over the world we don't
actually have a system of sharing
information about genomic variants even
though the clinical interpretation going
back to our original case study it's
quite clear that over time the world is
going to be a better place if we can
share information about the clinical
information what we know about the
clinical implications of genomic
variants but one of the one of the flies
in the ointment is that we don't have
strong incentives for sharing the
information and in fact if you've got a
big proprietary database which myriad
had based on almost two million tests
that they had done mainly on Europeans
and North Americans why would they share
that it's in their interest to keep that
as a private area database but if all of
the laboratories do that then we're
never going to be able to do the kind of
global collective interpretation that we
need to be able to do so this is the
policy dilemma that face faces us right
now and that's
why the idea of genomic data sharing was
seen as one of the hardest problems to
solve and as I've alluded to the
commercial incentives are actually a big
part of of the issue that we're facing
these days because there are many many
more companies out there doing many many
more kinds of things than there were in
1996 when the Bermuda principles were
enunciated there are labs that do
interpretation there are labs that do
genetic testing and hand off the
interpretation there are labs that are
doing clinical testing ancestry testing
and some labs are specializing in
prenatal testing of serum based or
plasma based DNA others are only doing
genomic testing so there are lots of
different kinds of labs out there and
there are also different kinds of data
bases all over the world and lots of
people trying to make sense of this
information under very different
business models so turning now again to
the brca1 and 2 what's the state of
affairs now the data I'm showing here on
the the Venn diagram is the state of
affairs that at the beginning of 2015
where if you looked at the top 5 sources
of data about the variants in these two
very important genes brca1 and brca2
what you notice is the biggest lobes and
these Venn diagrams the clinvar and BRCA
lobes BRCA share lobes it turns out that
of all the variants that had been
discovered and put into public databases
by 2015 the largest number of them are
only in one of those five sources of
information that's available publicly
around the globe now the very common
variants are the ones that are dead
center in there that are in all of these
databases for example the three founder
mutations among the Ashkenazi Jewish
populations that account for most of the
risk in those populations so
komm variants are in all the databases
but the fact is we're discovering many
many variants still to this day after
millions of tests have been done
worldwide and we have more than 19
thousand variants in the public
databases and Mirian says it has about
twenty thousand in its database we don't
know whether there's how much overlap
there is because we don't have access to
the myriad databases
moreover we estimate that at least forty
thousand more single nucleotide
polymorphisms will be discovered in
these two genes because they're very big
genes and moreover if you include
insertions and deletions and
rearrangements there's an infinite
number of very very that's that are that
that could become apparent in these two
genes so we're gonna have a lot more
mutations discovered and we're gonna
discover most of those new mutations
when we do testing in populations in
Africa in Latin America in South Asia in
parts of the world where testing has not
been common and in the populations even
within the United States like Native
American populations Medicaid
populations and low-income populations
that have not been tested up-to-date so
just to give you an example a report
that came out from China just last year
found that when they did sequencing of
these two genes in people with breast
cancer more than 40% of the variants
they discovered in brca1 and 2 were not
reported in the public database that
they used for comparison the breast
cancer information core at NIH what that
tells us is as we go into new
populations will be finding different
variants that are important to those
populations where are we now for these
two genes well we know that more than
3700 of the variants are associated with
disease but we're also discovering that
we don't have firm information about how
strongly those associations how strong
those associations are and sometimes we
make
mistakes in both directions most of the
variants of unknown significance are
actually going to turn out to not be
disease-causing we know that because as
we go into populations we will discover
that there are lots of people walking
around with variants that don't ever get
breast or ovarian cancer or other things
that are associated with these two genes
but we have to go through this process
of beginning to understand which
variants are disease associated in which
aren't and it's only going to work if we
do that by testing all over the world so
what's beginning to imagine is the
formation of a commons for sharing data
it's beginning to nucleate around the
brca1 and 2 genes in part because of
several shared characteristics that are
really unusual one is as I mentioned in
2013 the Supreme Court invalidated the
US patents on brca1 and 2 genes what
that meant is new laboratories within
hours of when the Supreme Court
announced its decision laboratories
begin to offer tests other than myriad
genetics well there are a lot of those
labs you can get tests for BRCA at more
than a dozen laboratories in the United
States and dozens more around the world
and all of those laboratories have a
strong incentive to be able to make good
sound clinical inferences on the BRCA
mutations and it that is going to
require pooling of all the testing
that's going on all over the world
getting those into common public
databases where the clinical inferences
can be creditably and verifiably
interpreted and then turn that into a
clinical resource so that's beginning to
happen genome-wide by the formation of
databases such as the clinvar database
that is run by the National Library of
Medicine but the flow of information
into clinvar is kind of bumpy and it's
not complete and it's not
completely global so in the case of
brca1 and 2 a community has begun to
form the Global Alliance for genomics
and health was formed in 2013 and one of
its flagship process projects from the
very beginning was something called BRCA
Challenge which was precisely about
getting global data sharing to begin to
happen the BRCA challenge has created a
resource called the BRCA exchange it's
basically a link to all these databases
to keep track of what do we know about
the variants that have been discovered
and reported into these various
databases and it's linked to an expert
interpretation framework a consortium of
experts from all over the world called
enigma and another consortium that's
looking at the things that influence
thus the the severity of and the timing
of variants in these two genes brca1 and
2 so all sorts of consortium have begun
to coalesce to try to create a Commons
and because of the former monopoly
everybody has an incentive to share
their data to catch up to the
proprietary databases that already exist
so this is underway and it's very clear
that the process of interpreting
variants for brca1 and 2 is far ahead of
what it is for most other genes that
haven't been tested for two decades and
we're gonna have to go through this
process of narrowing down the number of
variants that we don't know how to
interpret over time so that's kind of
the policy process process that were
faced with so how are we going to do
that interpretation well as we think
about incorporating this into people's
lives we've got a lot of issues that are
going to come to the surface one is
we've all come to an agreement that in
fact before you get a genetic test you
better know what you're getting into so
we have to have a framework for doing
genetic test counseling pre and post and
especially for people who get a
as a result to help them interpret their
result
moreover we need the different labs to
have standards for how the data are
reported interpreted and all these
layers of interpretation that we talked
about for the interpretation even of
something as simple as a single genomic
variant we have to have a system of
standards and interpretive frameworks
that people agree this is the best that
we have these days and we also need to
have labs that are testing each other's
interpretation and making sure that they
get the same results so we need a system
that does that we also need a system
that says when we change our
interpretation of the variant and this
will happen we will discover new
information that says what we used to
think was disease-associated
is not always disease-associated or it's
only disease associated in certain
families or in certain environmental
conditions we need to get that
information back to the people who have
already been tested and also get that
reclassification information into the
system and we need to know the standards
for when do you do that how what's the
level of evidence that you need before
you go back to people and say hey we
changed how we're interpreting the
variant that you have in your body
so these are all policy questions that
are being at there addressed in real
time and the brca1 and 2 genes are among
the places where that's going to be
taking place here are some of the
organizations that are involved in
trying to orchestrate that i've alluded
to all of them earlier in the talk
except that i don't think i mentioned
the the belgian database loaded that has
been involved in this space for quite
some time
and the human variome project which is a
a global effort to share data about many
genes not just the brca1 and 2 genes so
the goals here are to share the data in
such a way that science can advance and
that people facing decisions about what
whether they want to have prophylactic
mastectomies or Sall Pingo or
Tamizh that is the removal of both
breasts and both ovaries and fallopian
tubes in order to prevent the origin of
cancer in those people who are at very
high risk those are pretty high stakes
decisions to be made and we want to be
making those with the very best
information available those that's the
goal of the BRCA challenge and the idea
of the BRCA challenge was first to
create this data resource which is the
BRCA exchange which has been in
existence for about a year and a half
and it has as I've mentioned before has
19,000 variants in it and it has its
link to the enigma consortium that is
the formal way of trying to interpret
the clinical significance of these
variants and it is now trying to build
the interfaces to connect to patients
and to non-specialists physicians as
more and more people are getting access
to genetic testing as it becomes much
more widespread and less expensive so
what can we do to improve the disclosure
of information and the flow of data we
don't have standards for any of the
things that I'm talking about here but
there are some things that we can do and
some people have begun to do some of
these things it could be that payers
will decide as Aetna has that they will
only pay for tests when the labs that
are creating the tests agree that
they're going to share data with public
databases where the findings can be
verified so one payer has made that
decision the Centers for Medicaid and
Medicare services has not and most most
health programs around the world have
not made that policy decision but they
could the accreditation of laboratories
and the certification of individual lab
directors pathologists oncologists and
other users of the data could also be
made contingent on agreeing that if
you're making clinical decisions you're
going to do it in an evidence based
framework and that evidence based
framework requires the sharing of data
into public databases we already have
standards that you don't get to publish
something unless you present enough data
and enough information that others can
reach the same conclusion but
unfortunately while that is a standard
it is not one that is widely and
universally adopted so we need to
enforce that standard and finally the
Food and Drug Administration has been
talking about regulating the laboratory
to develop tests that are most relevant
for the kinds of tests that are taking
place in the genomic space there's been
a kind of a start and stop process where
FDA has been trying to think about it in
in 2016 the Food and Drug Administration
released a white paper about the
prospect of possibly certifying or at
least listing and saying these are
databases that are that we trust to make
clinical or inferences based on genomic
information that's that they're trying
to stay ahead of the curve at the Food
and Drug Administration and at the
European Medicines Agency and other
places around the world
that are facing these issues but we
don't have those standards in place and
this is a place to stay tuned for what
the policies are going to be and finally
us those of us who are health
professionals or genetic counselors or
even just people who care about this
stuff have ethical norms and standards
and the American College of medical
genetics and genomics has standards that
implicitly imply that you should be
sharing data if you're making clinical
inferences or trying to advance science
and the AMA past's two years ago passed
a statement of ethics that said if
you're playing in this space sharing
data is one of your ethical obligations
so we have many policy levels ranging
from normative that is
ethical obligations to things that would
matter in terms of money and
certification and the ability to do our
work
so it's this is not a source of despair
and going back to the idea that this was
really important but almost completely
impossible to solve I think over the
last two or three years it's become more
apparent that they actually are some
things that we can do and that a Commons
could emerge from current practices so
I'll finish by pointing out the fact
that that we I'm this slide is about a
grant that has been given to Baylor
College of Medicine led by Amy McGuire
they're a lawyer bioethicists we've been
studying for the past three years how do
we build a medical information Commons
and our case study of brca1 and 2 is
just an example of trying to build a
medical information Commons and to
generalize this issue it's quite
apparent that the similar issues are
going to come up with imaging of MRI
imaging or PET imaging or other kinds of
imaging for poor medical information
that comes through medical records for
claims data we're going to have the same
kind of issue that emerges for data of
many kinds but I focused here on sharing
data about genomic variants in part
because we have this norm of open
science that has been so productive and
so amazing and it is also one of the
places where the technology is becoming
cheaper much more widely available and
the flow of data is going to be coming
in much faster and we need to learn how
to deal with it so with that I'll turn
it over to our moderator and we'll turn
to questions and answers thank you thank
you dr. Robert cook again for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the
the question drop-down box located on
the far left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for let's get started
our first question is what
why do laboratories want to share their
data why not keep them as a proprietary
asset so that's a really good question
and there's no simple answer in part for
the following reasons right now some
labs actually do have an attendant to
keep their data as a proprietary secret
and that's because they have access to
the public data and they also have
access to their own data and when you're
in that situation especially if you've
got a really big database that's that's
quite useful you actually don't want to
share those data and for good good B's
and business reasons you're not going to
share the data but the situation for
example with BRCA and actually this is
going to be the situation for most other
genes throughout the human genome in
most cases no one laboratory has enough
data to do a really good job of
interpreting all of the variants that
they're coming across and therefore
everyone has an incentive to make the
process of identifying and interpreting
the variants that we come across in a
global sense much more reliable and no
one laboratory is going to have the
resources to do it but let's go to that
situation that existed in the United
States until 2013 when the Supreme Court
invalidated the patents because myriad
had done two million tests on people
mainly in Europe and North America they
had a very large data base and for the
years from around 1998 until 2013 in the
United States they were the only
laboratory that was doing BRCA testing
on a large scale that actually didn't
work in other parts of the world and I
think if we added up
the testing that was done in other
laboratories all over the world it would
be more or less the same amount of data
as myriad has in its database but myriad
had its own database and it was keeping
track of all that stuff and therefore it
has the largest individual database on
BRCA variants the other labs though that
entered that space in 2013 and began to
legally offer genetic testing um they
had a pretty strong incentive to share
data because they aren't just doing DNA
sequencing they're doing DNA sequencing
and saying you have a variant and we're
going to help you interpret that variant
we're gonna report to your doctor and to
you what that variant means is it
associated with disease or isn't it and
in that situation all of the labs all
over the world have a very strong
incentive to share their data get into
public databases because what happens if
they don't share their data is every
single one of those laboratories has to
build up its own database and its own
algorithms for interpreting the data and
that's really expensive and it's hard
and if the system were working properly
what we would have is a set of public
data resources that everyone can go to
that contains the most reliable the most
current data that we can find and also
can be used for whatever interpretive
framework you want to apply to it but it
becomes a common data pool for the whole
world for making valid clinical
inferences and in even in the case of
marriage' nedick's eventually the
proprietary value of it's its own
internal database will dissipate because
there's just no way that myriads gonna
do all the testing for the whole world
moreover just to make the point that
came up during a presentation myriad
there are lots of populations where they
don't have the data at all and yet
people are migrating all over the world
these days and genetic testing is going
on all over the world and even somebody
who's sending a sample
myriad genetics from some other country
they may come across a variant where
Miriah doesn't know how to interpret it
and in the long run the whole system is
going to work a whole lot better if we
manage to come up with a system that
allows us to share data and put the
common elements that we all care about
collectively into a central resource and
then allow all the businesses to compete
on grounds other than access to the data
thank you our next question is what are
the most valuable resources of data for
the brca1 and brca2 genes after two
decades of testing so the most common
variants in these two genes have already
been discovered in fact they were the
variants that allowed us to discover the
the brca1 and 2 genes in the first place
those are families with with
demonstrable inheritance of cancer risk
and the most common of those are of
course the ones you're going to stumble
across first as you're looking at very
big families that that clearly have
clusters of cancer what we're
discovering now is more and more rare
variants in these two genes so that
process is going to go on for a very
long time even in populations that have
been tested because we know that there
are tens of thousands of variants still
left to be found but the other thing
that is really interesting about certain
diseases and it includes the cancers
like B are like breast and ovarian
cancer associated with brca1 and 2 and
some other diseases like Alzheimer's
disease for example these are diseases
that have onset after reproductive age
and therefore there's not strong
selective pressure that forces them that
that means if you've inherited a
mutation you're less likely to have kids
and in that situation it's much more
likely that you're gonna have individual
founder populations
in different populations all over the
world so it turns out that the most
common variants in Mexico or Iceland or
Nigeria or China are not going to be the
same as the three Ashkenazi Jewish
population variants that are commonly
associated with breast and ovarian
cancer and brca1 risk so we're going to
be discovering the most common variants
in different populations all over the
world and what that means is the the
data that are most valuable are the data
in populations that haven't been tested
yet so that's number one number two is
populations where there is fairly common
marriage among relatives which means
that mutations that is variants are more
likely to be inherited so why does that
matter for the interpretation of
variants well it turns out that one of
the rules for figuring out whether a
variant is cancer associated is a kind
of a heuristic a rule of thumb that too
bad mutations in the same gene don't
don't survive into becoming a a viable
fetus and so if you've got a variant
that has been inherited that you don't
know how to interpret you say here's a
variant we don't know how to interpret
and you find that it's been inherited
with a known disease associated variant
it's less likely that that variant is
disease associated the one that you
don't know how to interpret because if
it were then you wouldn't be seeing it
in a living human being so it's not a
complete you know it's not a law of
nature
but it's a heuristic that's quite
powerful and if you find that in lots of
people you can be pretty confident that
that variant is not a disease-causing
variant so testing in populations that
haven't been tested and particularly in
populations that have consanguineous
marriage would be the most powerful
sources of new information about brca1
and 2 our next question is there in 20
thousand genes and each has many
variants how will we ever learn what
they mean so I guess maybe the answer to
that is never we probably won't really
but boy there's a lot of stuff that we
can do especially if we develop a system
and going back to this idea of the
commons part of the reason that that
folks are paying attention to the brca1
and 2 genes in particular is that it's
not just that we've been testing for two
decades but in addition to that these
two genes are associated with breast and
ovarian cancer which is also linked to
very active and activated groups of
people who care about breast and ovarian
cancer and are very effective at
building policy and coming up with
standards and there's a lot of political
energy and a lot of political will to
solve this problem so there's a
political aspect to this and moreover if
we build a system that works for these
two genes we should be able to build a
system that works for other genes
because a database actually doesn't care
about what gene is in it's what gene
you've got data on most of the
informatics structures don't actually
care about that so if we build the
system to allow data to flow it should
allow us to do that and one of the other
things that's distinctive about brca1
and 2 is when you get a genetic testing
result you can actually do something
about it and you change clinical
decisions that's true for a lot of other
genes but because of that fact there's
been a real reason to the stakes are
really high and therefore there's been a
strong incentive to make sure that we're
doing this right and what I'm hoping is
that that will spill over to other
disease conditions like like the
epilepsy
use like the cardiovascular diseases
that are associated with genetic risk so
that's kind of where we are it's
absolutely true these are probably two
of the most thoroughly studied genes in
the human genome along with cystic
fibrosis and Huntington's disease and
Alzheimer's disease and a few others but
boy most of those 20,000 genes we don't
know and we do know that several hundred
of those are probably going to be
associated with one condition or another
so we do have a long way to go but we
also have a set of solutions that we
might be able to apply if we get the
system to work right for the ones that
we're working on right now thank you
okay it looks like we have time for one
more question my next question is what
are the most promising policy changes
might encourage sharing of Geneva so I
think the single most powerful incentive
for sharing data would be for payers to
say we will not pay for a genetic test
unless that we can verify that the
system is working and that that test has
been done in such a way that it can be
verified so moving away from trust us
just pay us for the result to a system
where the labs are constantly making
sure that they actually detect the
variants they say they are detecting and
moreover that the system of interpreting
those variants is reliable and the
reason that I think it's the payment for
the genetic tests that's the most
powerful source of leverage is because
most of the data even now for brca1 and
2 is flowing in not from research labs
so the journal and the publication
standards and things like that they're
important but they won't get us where we
need to go and usually the conditions of
payment are really really
important in driving the system because
at the end of the day money talks and
drives policy so if we could get a norm
that payers say we don't pay you unless
you play by the rules and we come up
with a set of rules that create a robust
Commons that enables us to make the best
interpret interpretations of genomic
variants that we can then I think we've
solved a pretty big problem and I turn
to those payers like the Centers for
Medicaid Medicaid and Medicare services
and the private payers in the United
States and the national health systems
in France in Germany in Switzerland in
Australia and Canada
if those players all agreed that you
need to set up a verifiable and
independent system that includes data
sharing as a criterion I think we've got
the problem
90% solved thank you I would like to
once again thank dr. Robert cook Teigen
for his presentation I would also like
the thing labrys for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I wanna let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing the July of 2018
you'll receive an email from laborat
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who might have missed a tape like that
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon bye